hey guys I'm Ryan Wright from all-time
movies we are gonna check out top 10
porn stars turned actresses I'm sure
I've heard of all them so let's do this
I'm sure you getting big in the porn
industry is very hard but some actresses
are so big they spill over into
mainstream movies hey I'm Chris and I
spent many hours watching these movies
to bring you this list of the top 10
porn actresses who made it big they're
mostly just showed it is number 10 jenna
jameson yeah for my sake suck it up it's
a war out there sister
jenna jameson is probably the most
famous name in porn since linda lovelace
started a movie about profound esophagi
she made her big splash outside the
hard-core world in Howard Stern's Mehta
movie private park is the first naked
lady in the history of radio sans
panties sans bra I am shocked
so am i it's disgraceful we should be
taken off the air and has since starred
in loads of horror movies and spoofs
oh she probably peaked with zombie
strippers and by Pete I mean climax let
me get the Big O I mean the big tires
really hard number nine
brioche oh yeah nothing like every one
of my videos shut you [ __ ] mods bree
olson made a pretty impressive 280 porn
films in just 5 years before making it
straight in the mainstream does this
mean we're not gonna have sex in my ass
anymore she recently made it into human
centipede 3 which calls itself a polemic
movie yeah okay sure number 8 chasey
Lane who's that if you don't tell me
where Gaz mo is I'll screw you today no
she's not just the subject of a
Bloodhound Gang song
chasey Lane also appeared in South Park
guys's porn spoof Orgazmo Spike Lee is
he's got game and demon light one of the
Tales from the Crypt films just let me
get out I gotta find her if she can
pinch me any time number 7 Ginger Lynn
right it is the Flying Nun of these
people hey remember the Wing Commander
games yeah of course you do their
boasted live-action cut scenes featuring
illustrious stars like a washed-up Mark
Hamill and of course Ginger Lynn I just
hope the tests pass nuts I'm Krystal
only touches no question
famous for hood dirty talking in pornos
today the Charlie Sheen for a while
which landed her role in 80s brat pack
Weston young guns - since then she's
appeared in American Pie Bandcamp and of
course the Devil's Rejects that's not a
bad record actually number six stormy
Daniels I want you to put your penis on
anymore you're only Andy I want to do
lots lots of sexy hot things with you
stormy Daniels ran for Senate I swear I
arrived honestly look it up just look it
up on Wikipedia not Google video oh my
god his heart stopped get it up that's
you're on how you do CPR anyway when she
wasn't giving Republican rivals a hard
time she turned up in the 40 year old
virgin knocked up and finding bliss
number five Karen Lange car let's sit
down with my moment classic Karen Lange
car plays the main character in the
tourist French revenge thriller Bazemore
in English that means either kiss me or
rape me depending on which church you go
to
so for the phone she performed and
simulated penetration and fellatio she
left the porn industry but died in 2005
of a drug overdose ah for final film
black bastard number 12 number 4 bridge
and powers he clap on Sunset in
beautiful Hollywood Bridgette powers has
actually been in some pretty major films
like here in Swat and here in
confessions of a dangerous mind there is
my George Clooney before that though she
starred in 70 porn films she left the
industry because she only wanted to do
scenes with condoms which her male
co-stars refused to do her latest film
was big money Restless huge hit number
three Veronica Hart and Veronica
Ronni Kot makes it to number three
because she's actually played some real
characters in some serious artists poems
not just softcore cameos and the
agreement on the money settlement has
been taken care of director Paul Thomas
Anderson Causton Boogie Nights and
Magnolia and called her the Meryl Streep
of porn nice number two Traci Lords
Traci Lords has had a pretty rockin
career first she made a massive scandal
when it turned out she'd lied about her
age to make porn movies in her teens
then she went on to act opposite Johnny
Depp and appear in virtuosity with
Denzel Washington and Russell Crowe oh
yeah
tradition blade and more recently she
was in Zack and Miri Make a Porno Sue
Ellen it's a little something I picked
up during bachelor parties her name
bubbles comes around I suppose number
one side seen so many of her videos oh
yes sasha grey is the person most likely
lessness to be recognized for her work
outside of porn des moines after a
recurring role on tv's entourage of
course the high point of any actresses
career well just jealous
she played Negroes in would you rather
open windows opposite Elijah Wood comic
book movie the scribbler and the
girlfriend experience
directed by Steven Soderbergh and
somehow she still manages to take all of
her clothes off but hey she's been a big
advocate for the porn industry and she's
raised my awareness that's for sure hi
I'm Steve Kerr you're aboard the
enterprise
well there we go
was it as good for you as it was for me
did some of the phones on this list
surprise you let me know what you think
in the comments below and hey if you
love bad sakes or check out this list
okay
okay so you know this is an interesting
subject because I have a theory that if
some porn at a big porn star decided to
take acting seriously not like I'm gonna
do acting so I can make more money like
if they wanted to really do acting I
feel like they could be good at it
because they're willing to literally
expose themselves they'll definitely go
for it like if you're willing to show
yourself having sex on camera so it's
such a private moment and you're making
it so public and you have to really sell
it like I feel like they'd have enough
courage to show other sides of them yeah
yeah that's that's a bralette point
yeah like sasha grey she seems like
she's like really into everything when
someone is doing something to her god I
wish I could show you a video but I
never did her but man she is really hot
man [ __ ] she started she was like 18 or
something it's bold choice bold choice
oh Boldman you know what smart because
now she has a real career yes she does
mm-hmm I've always said to the young
gals and guys when you're 18 do cool no
no dear kid and Bree Olson I really like
bree olson man she another hot one
I didn't know she stopped honestly I
didn't know anyone in these Wow
no no one you watch porn no no I don't
watch porn why um I don't know have you
ever seen a mourner don't know actually
I've never seen you never seen a porno
I'm just um it's not like I'm like oh my
god no it's just like it's never come up
I've not found my
ever just found myself in a situation
where people are like you should really
really watch a porno you don't never do
by yourself
I just never had the desire I'm one hug
come youporn calm redtube don't not that
late next video is calm obviously I am
sorry I've just never 89 calm or had the
desire um big black dick girl you really
know these really well yeah I've never
been to big blacks black dicks calm does
not hear tight yeah they scare me
nothing black people the penises scary
huge I say fans of this channel vote
that Cassandra Michaels does a porn
reaction
boat put your comment below and check
out her channel and comment on her
videos that she must do a porn react oh
god yes no yeah you can't make me yes
and we're gonna Hakeem like the vote see
how many people voted I mean I could
tell you I don't make its ally and
didn't you got to do it as when she gets
50 votes
she doesn't know 50 no 50 no anyway guys
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Cassandra Michael's Channel
has a lot of original cuts regional
covers has a lot of original songs on
there some covers mainly music based
it's good Channel and you should check
out us on Facebook Instagram Twitter and
I have a volunteer scope I do snapchat
no man you need to get in time the life
to get in yeah
Cameron Andrew Williams hi I'm Cameron
I've been watching your channel since
late last year I think anyway I mean
actually get a shadow from some of the
coolest people on YouTube I also have a
question what would your action be if
you got your own TV show no that'd be my
reaction my reaction okay is it here I
just got I feel I gotta feel this - in a
week I gotta think about it again I need
you to feed me the line of hey Ryan it's
official you're getting a TV show
okay Ryan it's official you're getting a
TV show sweet let's smoke some pot cause
I should probably really accurate